i didn't feel that the turing test was
really the right way to calibrate how
intelligent
an algorithm could be but to linger on
that do you think it's pos
because you've come up with some
incredible tests
later on tests on algorithms right yeah
that are
uh like strong reliable robust across
a bunch of different classes of
algorithms but
returning to this emotional mess that is
intelligence
do you think it's possible to come up
with the test
that's as iron-clad as some of the
computational complexity work well i
think the greater question is whether
it's possible to achieve
human level level intelligence
right so that's so first of all let me
at the philosophical level do you think
it's possible to create algorithms
that reason and
would seem to us to have the same kind
of intelligence as human beings
it's an open question it seems to me
that most of the achievements have
uh acquire
operate within a very limited set of
ground rules and
for a very limited precise task
which is a quite different situation
from the
processes that go on in the minds of
humans which
where they have to sort of function in
changing environments
they have emotions they have um
[Music]
physical attributes for acquiring for
exploring their environment
they have intuition they have desires
emotions and
i don't see anything in the current
achievements of what's called
ai that come close to that capability i
don't think there's any
computer program which
surpasses a six-month-old child in terms
of
comprehension of the world
do you think this complexity of human
intelligence
all the cognitive abilities we have all
the emotion
do you think that could be reduced one
day or just
fundamentally can it be reduced to an a
set of algorithms or an algorithm
so can a touring machine achieve human
level intelligence
i am doubtful about that i guess the
argument
in favor of it is that the human brain
seems to achieve
what we call intelligence cognitive
abilities of
different kinds and if you buy the
premise that the human brain is
just an enormous intricate
interconnected set of switches so to
speak
then in principle you should be able to
diagnose what that interconnection
structure is like
characterize the individual switches and
build a
simulation outside but
why that may be true in principle that
cannot be the way we're
eventually going to tackle this problem
it's
you know you know that
that does not seem like a feasible way
to go about it
so it there is however an existence
proof that
um uh if you believe that the brain is
is just a network of
of neurons operating by rules i guess
you could say that that's an existence
proof of the ability to build
the capabilities of a mechanism
but it would be almost impossible to
acquire the information unless we got
enough insight into the operation of the
brain
you